you know the last days of it
my father
um got this idea because Khrushchev had
sent two letters
he sent one letter that was conciliatory
and then he sent a letter that after his
Joint Chiefs and the warmongers around
him saw that letter and they disapproved
of it they sent another letter that was
extremely belligerent
and my father had the idea let's just
pretend we didn't get the second letter
and reply to the first one
and then he went down to do Brennan
and who was he met the Brennan in the
justice department and the Brennan was
the Soviet Ambassador and they you know
they proposed this settlement which was
a secret settlement
Eric Khrushchev would withdraw the
missiles from Cuba Khrushchev had put
them into Cuba because we had put
missiles you know nuclear missiles in in
turkey and
Italy and my uncle's secret deal was
that if he if Khrushchev removed them
this is from Cuba within six months he
would get rid of the Jupiter missiles in
Turkey but if Khrushchev told anybody
about the deal it was off
so if if news got out about that secret
deal it was off that was the actual deal
and Khrushchev complied with and then my
uncle complied with it how much of that
part of human history turned on the
decisions of one person
I think that's one of the you know
because that of course the perennial
question right but it is history kind of
on uh
an automatic pilot and you know uh human
decisions the decisions of leaders
really only have you know a marginal or
incremental bearing on what is going to
happen anyway but I think that is the
and historians argue about that all the
time
I think that that is a really good
example of a play a a place in human
history that uh that literally the world
could have ended if
we had a different leader in the White
House and the reason for that is that
there were as I recall 64 gun
emplacements you know missile missile
emplacements
each one of those emplacements had a
crew of about 100 men
and they were Soviets
so on they were and they we didn't know
whether we had a couple of questions
that my uncle asked
Alan or asked the CIA and he asked
Dulles was already gone but he asked the
CIA and he asked um his military brass
because they all wanted to go in
everybody wanted to go ahead and my
uncle said my uncle asked to see the
aerial photos and he examined those
personally and that's why it's important
to have a leader in the White House who
can push back on on their bureaucracies
he
um and then he asked them
you know are those who's Manning those
missile sites and are they Russians and
if they're Russians and we bomb them
uh are they isn't it going to force
Khrushchev to then go into Berlin
and that would be the beginning of a
Cascade effect that would you know I
like the nuclear confrontation
and the the uh the military perhaps said
to my uncle oh we don't think you'll
have uh you know we don't think he'll
have the uh the guts to do that so he
went my uncle was like that's what
you're betting on
and uh you know they all wanted him to
go in they wanted him to bomb the sides
and then invade Cuba and he said if we
bomb those sites we're going to be
killing Russians and it's kind of force
it's going to provoke Russia into some
response and the obvious response is for
them to go into Berlin
oh but the thing that we didn't know
then that we didn't find out until I
think uh you know there was a it was
like a 30-year anniversary of the Cuban
Missile Crisis in Havana
and what we learned then was that from
the Russians who came
to that event it was like a symposium
where everybody on both sides talked
about it and we learned a lot of stuff
than and never nobody knew before
one of the insane things the most insane
thing that we learned was that the the
weapons were already the nuclear
warheads were already in place they were
ready to fire
and that the authorization to fire
was made was delegated to each of the
gun gun crew commanders so there were 60
people
who had all had authorization of fire if
they felt themselves under attack
so you have to believe that at least one
of them would have launched and that
would have been the beginning of the end
and you know if they if anybody had
launched you know we knew what would
happen my uncle knew what would happen
because he asked again and again what's
going to happen and they said 30 million
Americans will be killed
but we will kill 130 million Russians so
we will win and that was a victory for
them
and my uncle said later said he talked
he told Arthur Schlesinger and Kenny
O'Donnell he said those guys he called
them the salad brass the guys with all
of this stuff on their chest
and he said he said those guys they
don't care
because they know that if it happens
that they're going to be in the charge
of everything they're the ones who are
going to be running the world after that
so for them you know it was there was an
incentive to to kill 130 million
Russians and 30 million Americans by my
uncle he would have this correspondence
with the crew chef they were secretly
corresponding with each other and that
is what saved the world is that they had
that both of them had been Men of War
you know Eisenhower famously said it
will it will not be a man of war
it will not be a soldier who starts
World War III because a guy who's
actually seen it knows how bad it is and
my uncle you know had been In the Heat
of the South Pacific
his boat had been cut into by a Japanese
Destroyer
um his many three of his criminal be
killed one of them badly burned he he
pulled that guy with a lanyard in his
teeth
six miles to an island in the middle of
the night and then they hid out there
for 10 days you know and
um and you know he came back like I said
he was the only uh president of the
United States that are in the Purple
Heart
um meanwhile Khrushchev had been at
Stalingrad which was the worst place to
be on the planet you know probably in
the 20th century other than you know and
Al Switzerland one of the death camps
it was uh you know it was it was the
most ferocious horrific war with people
starving people you know committing
cannibalism uh you know eating the dogs
the cats eating their shoe leather
we're easing to death by the thousands
Etc
a crew Chef did not want the last thing
he wanted was a war and the last thing
my uncle wanted was sort of war and they
but the CIA did not know anything about
Khrushchev and the reason for that
is the there was a mole at Langley
so that every time the CIA got a spy
in the Kremlin he would immediately be
killed so if they had no eyes in the
gremlin you know there were literally
hundreds of Russia of Russian supplies
Who had who were defected the United
States and were in the Kremlin who were
killed during that period
they had no idea anything about
Khrushchev about how he saw the world
and they saw the Kremlin itself as a
monolith you know that it is uh is kind
of you know the same way that we look at
Putin today that you know it's all they
have this ambition of world conquest and
that's it's driving them and there's
nothing else they think about there are
absolutely single-minded about it
but actually there was a big division
between Khrushchev and uh and his Joint
Chiefs and his intelligence apparatus
and they and they both at one point
discovered they were both in the same
situation they were
surrounded by spies and military
personnel who were intent on going to
war and they were the two guys resisting
it so when my uncle my uncle had this
idea of you know being the peace
president
from the beginning he told Ben Bradley
his one of his best friends who you know
was run the publisher of the Washington
Post
with the editor-in-chief at that time he
said um
Ben Bradley asked him what is what do
you want in your gravestone and my uncle
said he kept the peace
he said
the principal job of the president of
the United States is to keep the country
out of War
and um and so when he first became
president he he actually agreed
to meet Khrushchev in Geneva to his
Summit and by the way Eisenhower had
wanted to do the same thing Eisenhower
wanted peace but his and he was going to
meet in Vienna
but that peace Summit was blown up he
was going to try to do
um
you know he was going to try to end the
Cold War Eisenhower was in the last year
of his of his in May of 1960.
but that was torpedoed by the CIA during
the U2 crash you know they sent a
YouTube over the over the Soviet Union
and it got shot down and then they told
and then Alan told us
all the Eisenhower to deny that we had a
program they didn't know that the
Russians had captured Gary France's
powers
and so when and and that blew up the
piece talks between Eisenhower and
Khrushchev and so you know they and
the uh there was a lot of tension
my uncle wanted to break that tension he
agreed to meet with
um
with Khrushchev in Vienna early on in
this term
he went over there and Khrushchev
snubbed him
khrushchev's lectured him imperiously
about the you know the
the terror of American imperialism and
and rebuff any you know they did agree
not to go into Laos they made an
agreement that kept the United States
kept my uncle from sending troops to
Laos
but
um it had been a disaster Vienna so then
we had a spy that used to come to our
house all the time I cut Georgie
going he was this Russian
spy my my parents had met at the embassy
they had gone to a party or a reception
that Russian Embassy and he had
approached them and they knew he was he
was a GRU agent and KGB he was both
oh he used to come around they really
liked him he was very attractive
he was always laughing and joking he
would do rope climbing contests with my
father he would do push-up contests with
my father he was uh he could do the
Russian dancing the Cossack dancing
and he would do that for us and teach us
that and he would and we knew he was a
spy too and this was at the time of you
know the James Bond films were first
coming out so it was really exciting for
us to have a actual Russian spot in our
house the state department was horrified
by it but um but anyway
when Khrushchev after Vienna
and after
um you know the pigs
on Khrushchev had second thoughts
and he sent this long letter to my uncle
and he didn't want to go through his in
his State Department
or his Embassy he wanted to enrun them
but and he was friends with
so he gave Georgie the letter and
Georgie brought it and handed it to
Pierre Salinger folded in the New York
Times
and he gave it to my uncle and it was
this beautiful letter which he said you
know um he my uncle had talked to him
about the children who were played you
know we played 29 grandchildren who were
playing in his yard and he's saying what
is our moral basis for making a decision
that could kill these children so
they'll never write a poem they'll never
participate in election they'll never
run for office how can we make how can
we can we morally make a decision that
is going to eliminate
life of these beautiful kids and
um he had said that to to Khrushchev and
Khrushchev wrote them this letter back
saying that he was now sitting as this
dotcha
on the Black Sea and
um that he was thinking about what my
uncle jack had said to him at Vienna and
he regretted very deeply not having
taken the olive leaf
that jacket offered him and then he said
you know it occurs to me now that we're
all on an arc and that there is not
another one and that the entire fate of
the planet
and all of its creatures and all of the
children are dependent on the decisions
we make and you and I have a moral
obligation to go forward with each
other's friends
and immediately after that this was you
know he sent that right after the Berlin
crisis in 1962
General Curtis LeMay
um tried to
um had tried to provoke a war
with a an incident at Checkpoint Charlie
which was
the the
entrance the entrance exit through the
Berlin Wall in Berlin and the Russian
tanks has come to the wall the U.S tanks
had come to the wall and there was a
standoff
and my uncle had had uh sent a message
to Khrushchev then through dobrin and
saying my back is at the wall I cannot I
have no place to back to please back off
and then we will back off and cruise
shaft took his word
packed his Tanks off first and then my
uncle ordered lamaid back Ian Lemay had
mounted bulldozer plows on the on the
front of the tanks to plow down the
Berlin wall and that and the Russian
sitcom so it was just you know it was
the right it was his generals trying to
provoke a war
and I'm
but they started talking to each other
then and then when he after he wrote
that letter they agreed that they would
install a hotline
so they could talk to each other and
they wouldn't have to go through
intermediaries and so at Jack's house on
the cape there was a red phone that we
knew if we picked up Khrushchev would
answer
and there was another one in the white
house yeah
and that but they knew it was important
to talk to each other you know and you
just wish that we had that kind of
leadership today